durante meses hemos estado trabajando de
cerca con el sector privado para
aumentar nuestra ciberdefensa es pulir
nuestra capacidad de responder a los
ciberataques rusos también hablé anoche
con el presidente es el escudo craneal y
le asegure que los eeuu junto con
nuestros aliados y socios en europa
respaldaremos al pueblo ucraniano
mientras defienden a su país
les daremos ayuda humanitaria para
aliviar su sufrimiento
los primeros días de ese conflicto la
propaganda rusa seguirá intentando
ocultar la verdad
diciendo que están siendo exitosos
en sus dos militares encontrado una vena
cimentada pero les había mostrado una y
otra vez como las rápidas ganancias ser
en el terreno
llevan a ocupaciones complicadas a una
desobediencia civil masiva y bueno
caminos cerrados en la estratégica en
las próximas semanas y meses
putin ha liberado un montón de dolor
sobre la gente ucraniana pero la gente
ucraniana ya conoce al menos 30 años de
independencia y ha repetido que no van a
tolerar que nadie intente hacer que su
país vuelva a ser lo que fue este es un
momento peligroso para toda europa y
para la libertad en todo el mundo
putin ha cometido un asalto contra los
principios que sostienen la paz mundial
pero ahora el mundo entero está viéndolo
con claridad putin el kremlin y sus
aliados del kremlin bueno ya sabe el
mundo como son esto no fue nunca un tema
de seguridad de su parte siempre era una
agresión
descarada el deseo de putin de tener un
imperio fuera como fuera al matonear a
los vecinos de rubia de rusia y hacer
los corruptos al cambiar las cosas por
la fuerza al elegir la guerra sin una
causa las acciones de putin
ponen en compromiso del mundo el futuro
del mundo su visión
[Música]
los eeuu y sus aliados y socios
emergerán de esta situación más fuertes
más unidos más determinados con un mayor
propósito la agresión de putin en contra
de ucrania terminará costándole a rusia
mucho económicamente y estratégicamente
nos aseguraremos de eso
putin será un paria en el escenario
internacional cualquier nación
que valore esta agresión será manchada
por la asociación
la historia está siendo escrita la
elección de putin de hacer una guerra
totalmente injustificable en sobre
ucrania
dejará a rusia mucho más débil y al
mundo al resto del mundo mucho más
fuerte la libertad la democracia la
dignidad humana estas son las fuerzas
son fuerzas mucho más poderosas que el
miedo y la opresión
no pueden ser extinguidas por tiranos
como putin y sus ejércitos
no pueden ser borradas de los corazones
de las personas de las esperanzas de las
personas sin importar la intimidación a
la violencia persisten
en la disputa entre la democracia y la
autocracia entre la soberanía y la
subyugación no cometan ningún error acá
no se confundan la libertad prevalecerá
dios bendiga al pueblo de una ucrania
libre y democracia y que dios proteja
nuestras tropas
soy yo
ap
tiene planes de hablar con el presidente
putin en este punto y qué interacciones
ha tenido con el gobierno ruso escuché
la primera parte tengo planes de hablar
con el presidente podría en este punto y
que comunicación tiene usted con
es un conflicto bastante grande ahora
que queremos asegurarnos de que no
resulta en un conflicto grande y la
manera es reuniendo todas las fuerzas
necesarias en las naciones del este de
europa y los miembros de la otan la otan
es más unida de lo que nunca ha estado y
no tengo ningún plan de hablar con putin
washington
trina
señor presidente usted no mencionó el
sistema swift en las sanciones hay
alguna razón por la cual los eeuu no
esté haciendo eso hay un desacuerdo
entre aliados
respecto del sistema swift y si rusia
debe ser parte de las sanciones que
estamos proponiendo sobre los bancos
tienen una consecuencia igual tienen
mayores consecuencias incluso que swift
en primer lugar en segundo lugar siempre
es una opción pero ahora esa no es la
posición del resto de europa
no sé si habéis
cecilia
abc
señor las sanciones han sido suficientes
para disuadir a vladimir putin de
avanzar este punto que es lo que lo va a
detener como
y cuando termina esto ve usted que él
quiera ir más allá de ucrania en la
segunda pregunta es esta la declaración
que él dio anoche la amenaza que emitió
que el occidente hablaras tiene unas
posibles consecuencias superiores está
en la maná sando con un golpe nuclear no
tengo idea cuál es su amenaza sé qué es
lo que ha hecho en primer lugar en
segundo lugar nadie esperaba que las
sanciones previnieran que algo sucediera
esto puede tomar tiempo y tenemos que
mostrar
determinación él sabe qué es lo que
viene entonces la gente de rusia sabe
qué es lo que ha pasado y qué es lo que
le ha traído de eso es que te trae esto
esto va a tomar tiempo no va a ocurrir
no va a decir por dios estas sanciones
vienen voy a tener que irme no vuelva a
probar la determinación del occidente y
nosotros vamos a mantenernos unidos
y vamos a causarle cosas pues que vaya
más allá ucrania sí
dos temas rápidamente primer lugar los
mercados están en decaída los precios
están aumentando en el gal si se habla
de la diferencia entre wall street y
main suite pero todo el mundo parece
van a empezar a sufrir las desventajas
económicas con qué tan difícil
económicamente sea poner para la gente
este país y tengo una pregunta más en
primer lugar no hay ninguna duda de que
cuando un gran poder nuclear
ataca e invade a otro país que el mundo
va a responder y los mercados pueden
responder en todo el mundo entonces no
hay ninguna duda
en primer lugar en segundo lugar
la noción de que esto vaya a durar por
un tiempo prolongado es bastante
improbable medida que sigamos
determinados imponiendo las sanciones
que vamos a imponer
sobre rusia apuntó cual es su siguiente
pregunta la siguiente pregunta es acaso
usted subestimó a putin no escribiría
todavía como lo hizo en el verano como
un adversario valeroso en ese momento él
lo era y yo lo dejé claro como
empresario y yo dije que en una persona
valerosa nunca lo suben si me he leído
la mayor parte de lo que el escrito no
no no estoy bueno usted ha escuchado el
discurso que él dijo apenas bueno unas
horas el puente porque él iba a ir
ucrania él tiene unas ambiciones
superiores en ucrania él quiere
realmente reestablecer la anterior unión
soviética de eso se trata esto y creo
que sus ambiciones son
completamente contrarias al lugar en el
que está el resto del mundo
usted tiene confianza de que estas
sanciones devastadoras vayan a ser tan
devastadoras como los misiles y las
balas y los tanques rusos
las balas misiles y tanques rusos en
ucrania sí seguro
presidente vaivén si las sanciones no
pueden detener al presidente putin qué
tipo de penalidad puede hacerlo yo no
dije que las sanciones pudieran
detenerlo usted está hablando de la
fuerza de estas sanciones por semanas sí
pero las amenazas de las sanciones y la
imposición de sanciones el efecto de las
sanciones y ver esos efectos son cosas
diferentes son cosas diferentes
y lo que va a pasar es que él empezará a
ver los efectos de las sanciones que
hará eso como cambiará eso su situación
por que debilitarán a su país tanto que
él tendrá que hacer una decisión muy
difícil
o se convierte en un segundo poder o
responde usted dice que las grandes
naciones no pueden bloquear cuando se
trata de esto se estableció esa idea
personalmente hablando de que las
sanciones personales a putin eran estaba
en la mesa bueno hay muchas cosas que
están en la mesa sancionar al presidente
putin sí porque no sancionarlo hoy señor
porque no sancionarlo
señor presidente si puede usted detalló
unas sanciones severas
habló del impacto duradero que tendría
pero dada la invasión de gran escala
dado que usted no está persiguiendo una
desconexión de rusia lo que se llama el
swift sistema bancario internacional u
otras sanciones a su disposición
respetuosamente señor que más está
esperando usted específicamente con las
sanciones que hemos impuesto esto excede
swift excede cualquier cosa que se haya
hecho antes de las sanciones que
impusimos han generado dos tercios
ángeles y que dos tercios del mundo se
unan a nosotros sus acciones profundas
tengamos una conversación en un mes o
dos y veremos si está funcionando pueda
preguntarle por tales que usted habló
con vladimir selenski ayer señor
cuál es el riesgo
de que estemos viendo el inicio de una
segunda guerra fría y acaso hay una
ruptura total entre la relación de rusia
y eeuu hay una ruptura total en las
relaciones entre eeuu y dioses y
continúan en este camino
en términos de guerra fría eso depende
tiene la vasta mayoría del resto del
mundo en completa posición con lo que él
está haciendo desde asia hasta
sudamérica hasta europa y en todo
alrededor del mundo entonces
va a ser un día muy frío para rusia la
idea ustedes no ver a mucha gente que
esté yendo a defenderlo
quiero hacer un seguimiento de estado
usted dirigiendo a china ayudar a aislar
a rusia está pidiéndole ustedes son
china
no estoy preparado para comentar eso en
estos momentos
[Música]
él tenía en su mano más levantadas y
gracias presidente que tanto le preocupa
que putin quiera ir más allá de ucrania
a otros países eeuu entre que
involucrarle e involucrarse así entre
países de la otan si él entra países de
lo tanto tendríamos que ser involucrados
estaremos involucrados lo único de lo
que estoy convencido es que si no lo
detenemos ahora él estará envalentonado
pero si no nos movemos ahora con estas
sanciones significativas él se verá
envalentonado miren
cada
puede hablar más de su conversación ser
presidente
[Música]
porque no sancionan a putin directamente
los centros por escuchar
dónde
india es uno de sus mayores delfín
aliados en defensa está en sincronía con
lo decidido con eeuu estamos en consulta
con india hoy no hemos resuelto este
tema completamente
y muchas gracias a todos muchas gracias